hace un tiempo le pedí a mi hijo de 10
años que me haga un dibujo de
fotosíntesis
vieron cómo son los chicos no para qué
pero después de un rato me hizo este
dibujo
después le dije sentate y vamos a
conversar de cambio climático y otra vez
no para qué pero apago dinei flash y se
sentó
y ahí me contó que en el colegio le
habían hecho ver una película que se
llama el viaje de gaia y trata de una
nena más o menos de su misma edad que
vive en el futuro un futuro gris
horrible los únicos seres vivos son los
seres humanos
todo el tiempo usan mascarillas para
respirar ojo no estamos con las
mascarillas
y el abuelo que era inventor le envía al
pasado 50 60 años atrás 2021 pongamos
en una máquina que el diseño y una carta
para que reparta en ese nuestro presente
sería
en esa carta que se le hace a las
personas que sean influyentes para poder
cambiar ese futuro tan feo en el que
estaban viviendo
vaya cuando llega a nuestro presente se
sorprende de los colores de las flores
de los animales que había conocido solo
en un libro que había encontrado en un
basural
de lo que dice la carta de lo que hablé
con mi hijo de diez años esa tarde
y de este dibujo les quiero comentar
algunas cosas
vamos a aprovechar el dibujo para
llevarnos un rato a nuestro al colegio a
la primaria cuantas veces vimos
fotosíntesis y no sabíamos bien para qué
servía las plantas son las únicas
capaces de tomar energía del sol agua y
minerales del suelo el dióxido de
carbono que nosotros exhalamos y las
maquinas combustionan para convertirla
en oxígeno y si me permiten un término
nuevo crecer generar biomasa
otro concepto también escolar es el de
la cadena trófica se acuerdan la
plantita el herbívoro el carnívoro el
carnívoro que se come al carnívoro es la
forma de transferir y almacenar energía
del sol a través de biomasa biomasa que
pasa de vegetal animal
por último voy a aprovechar este dibujo
para contarles algunas cosas de cambio
climático
algunas cosas de cómo llegamos hasta acá
y sobre todo cómo salimos de acá les voy
a hablar de cambio climático desde una
mirada distinta
dilemas asociados al cambio climático y
por último les vengo a traer un desafío
se suman
durante miles de años el ser humano
utilizó todo lo que tenía sobre la
naturaleza para alimentarse como fuente
de energía y como materiales
pero sabían hace 250 años en la
revolución industrial comenzó a utilizar
el carbón mineral en forma intensiva y
hace menos de 120 años descubrió el
petróleo como una fuente casi inagotable
de energía y de materiales
esos dos compuestos el petróleo y el
carbón es biomasa generada a través de
la fotosíntesis
pero hace 150 millones de años y parecía
inagotable y se están agotando
pero no sólo eso hoy sabemos que son los
principales responsables de los gases de
efecto invernadero
generamos tanto dióxido de carbono que
las plantas no pueden llegar a procesar
y generar transformar de nuevo en
oxígeno
a su vez sintetizamos del petróleo
nuevos materiales con un montón de
ventajas pero que hoy sabemos que no se
degradan y que se acumulan de quienes
estamos hablando
los plásticos
por suerte la humanidad
es pensó que si seguimos por este camino
vamos a terminar muy mal y diseño
algunas estrategias de solución cómo
reciclar pasar de una economía lineal
donde extraemos consumimos y desechamos
a una energía a una perdón a una
economía circular que es
recuperar reutilizar y reciclar los
materiales que ya extrajimos de la
tierra ok a sintetizamos
la segunda estrategia tiene que ver con
la eficiencia energética y aquí la
movilidad eléctrica autos monopatines
motos eléctricas compren cumplen un rol
fundamental
pero también nosotros en nuestras casas
en nuestras oficinas
ojo no eliminamos el el uso de fósiles y
el los gases de efecto invernadero pero
lo optimizamos la tercera estrategia son
las energías limpias
es así no generan dióxido de carbono por
lo menos en su uso la eólica la
hidráulica
la solar
y en cuarto lugar les quiero mencionar
la bioeconomía un nuevo paradigma
económico mundial de que voy a charlar
unos minutos la vida economía
propone utilizar en lugar de biomasa
ancestral generada hace millones de años
los fósiles biomasa generada en tiempo
real este año el año pasado hace dos
años de esa manera logramos casi un
balance de carbono
neutro las plantas que están creciendo
están tomando absorbiendo el dióxido de
carbono que exhalamos o que combustión
amos con las máquinas
por otro lado autolimita nos quita esa
concepto de esto es infinito que nos dan
los fósiles
a su vez hay que utilizarla de forma
completa porque a la tierra le cuesta
muchísimo
obtener esa biomasa entonces tenemos que
utilizar cada parte
hay que utilizar la biomasa en el lugar
hay que procesarla y agregarle valor se
dice la biomasa viaja mal eso genera
enormes oportunidades de desarrollo
regional
y por último el modelo tiene que ser
sustentable de arranque esto quiere
decir que no nos pasen lo que no con los
fósiles y el ser humano está dentro de
ese sistema y la salud obviamente del
ser humano es muy importante
como ingeniero trabajé en un montón de
proyectos de bioeconomía aún sin saberlo
como una empresa que está acá a unos
kilómetros que utiliza desechos de la
industria frigorífica de queserías de la
cervecería para obtener productos de
alto valor proteico
exportar la mitad de la producción darle
trabajo a 120 personas
eso es utilizar la biomasa eso es bio
economía o una emprendedora local que
está estudiando como a partir de las
colillas de cigarrillos hacer nuevos
materiales
o hacer crecer hongos usar como sustrato
para que crezcan hongos comestibles eso
es reciclar
o un proyecto que se hacían bioplásticos
a partir de efluentes de la industria
láctea con bacterias con levaduras los
famosos bio materiales
otro proyecto que hacíamos energía
práctica a partir de sus productos de la
industria y sus productos agrícolas pues
fuentes desechos y obteníamos biogás
obtener biodiesel a partir del aceite de
soja esos son los biocombustibles todos
ejemplos de esta vía economía
hasta acá todo muy lindo no parece una
historia con final feliz
pero saben lo que me pasa en los grupos
de whatsapp que hablamos intercambiamos
de ecología del medio ambiente está
lleno de contradicciones de dilemas de
posturas radicalizadas y yo les dije que
le iba a hablar de dilemas
la misma plantita que se utiliza como
alimento también se puede utilizar como
combustible
vamos a alimentar máquinas cuando hay
gente que no come
tenemos que generar cada vez más biomasa
para reemplazar a los fósiles ya sabemos
que nos hacen mal pero para eso tenemos
que usar fitosanitarios herbicidas
insecticidas
plaguicidas
el uso irracional irresponsable
indiscriminado de esos fitosanitarios
nos están envenenando con las
fumigaciones
por otro lado para generar más biomasa
tenemos que correr nuestra línea de
producción pero también sabemos que el
desmonte de selvas y bosques atentan
contra la biodiversidad que necesitamos
para nuestra supervivencia
vengan los contras omnívoros vaca muerta
contra vaca viva desarrollo regional
contra no este es un discurso de las
multinacionales que se quieren quedar
con toda la plata saben que todas estas
cosas que dije son ciertas pero tenemos
que discutir las maduras maduramente
pasionalmente
encontrar límites desafíos
impactos
costo-beneficio de cada acción porque si
no las discutimos caemos en la inacción
y la inacción nos lleva inexorablemente
al futuro de gaia
por eso son los invito a pensar que
podemos hacer ustedes quieren el futuro
de gaya adonde viven allá
yo siento un enorme dolor y vergüenza de
dejar este mundo a mis hijos y mis
nietos
ustedes
entonces pasemos a la acción
habrán escuchado de sus padres y abuelos
argentina a principio del siglo 20 era
potencia estábamos entre los primeros 5
países del mundo mira de dónde estábamos
miran que quedábamos mira lo que somos
yo les aseguro que con la bioeconomía
podemos volver a estar en esos niveles
de ranking pero nosotros si después de
de no dejar pasar otra vez la
oportunidad
pero qué podemos hacer nosotros
está claro que como individuos reciclar
útil
ahorrar energía ahorrar agua
usar biomateriales biocombustibles
interiorizarlos de estos temas ponernos
en la práctica
contagiar al resto es re importante
pero yo les dije que les iba a traer un
desafío
tener su propio emprendimiento de triple
impacto los emprendimientos de triple
impacto generan ganancias económicas
beneficios sociales a quienes a sus
empleados a sus clientes a sus
proveedores
y tienen un impacto ambiental positivo
estamos hablando de tener nuestro propio
emprendimiento totalmente alineado a
nuestros valores supongo que todos los
que estamos acá queremos defender el
planeta
a su vez estos emprendimientos
muchos de ellos no necesitan tanto
capital si una muy buena idea que se
puede copiar y adaptar
y muchas pero muchas ganas a su vez hay
líneas de financiamiento que apoyan este
tipo de proyectos por eso les digo
que si quieren ayudar al medio ambiente
si quieren combatir el cambio climático
y están pensando en un emprendimiento
háganlo y piensen en fotosíntesis
gracias
[Aplausos]